[Music]
on july 3
2014 mercedes-benz announced their most
ambitious project yet
a future truck 2025 that would drive
itself the technology to create this
already exists and was brought together
in a system called
the highway pilot it provides safety
allows lower fuel consumption
and creates a better work environment
for professional truck drivers
mercedes-benz says the technology won't
do away with human drivers altogether
as they still need someone behind the
wheel it will merely serve as a backup
option if the driver needs some rest
over long distances there's lots more to
learn about the self-driving truck but
before we begin make sure you hit the
subscribe button
and ring that bell so you never miss a
video from simply tech
the truck of tomorrow will drive itself
and the road is there being paved by
systems and assistance already in use
today
using improved management systems and
cloud-based applications
will also enable fleet operators to save
a ton of money
the end goal here is to make roads safer
and help trucking companies keep
their drivers safe and boost their
productivity the self-driving trucks
from mercedes are made in collaboration
with daimler
a pioneer of automated driving with a
clear road map to creating the
autonomous truck
as part of this map they charted they
established the autonomous technology
group
as a global organization for automated
driving and bringing together
experts on this subject from around the
world the unit makes strategies ensures
implementations and carries out
all the research and development work
for autonomous vehicles
daimler though less well-known than
legacy car makers is still a huge
company
mercedes-benz is best known for their
luxury vehicles
but did you know they are actually a
subsidiary of daimler
daimler ag owns frightliner western star
mitsubishi fuso to name a few
they are one of the most successful
companies in the automotive industry
today
and one of the leading global suppliers
of premium cars and commercial vehicles
highly automated driving is
characterized as automatic travel
between two points without any
intervention or response from the driver
that's the basic definition in 2014
daimler trucks unveiled their
mercedes-benz future truck
the world's first automated truck and
was the first to demonstrate the
opportunities and potential these trucks
can have for the economy
and society in 2015 the fightliner
inspiration truck for the first road
license ever
for an automated commercial vehicle so
how does
it work alright time to get technical
the truck will have
active drive resist and detroit
assurance 5.0
with active lane assist which helps you
switch lanes safely
all of this already exists in mercedes
cars and daimler trucks
daimler is already bringing partially
automated driving features into series
production
they can break accelerate and steer on
their own
unlike systems that take the wheel only
above a specific speed limit
active drive assist partially automated
driving works in
all speed ranges the fusion of radar and
camera information provides active
lateral control
the future truck provides a taste of
developments in commercial vehicle
technology
and these will have an impact on
business models in the transport
industry
and take away a lot of the difficulties
truck drivers face in their profession
sustained attention tight schedules and
high traffic roads
place too many demands on drivers but
the intelligent interlinking of the
trucks assistance systems
down to the self-driving feature itself
will contribute significantly to vehicle
safety
the truck also features new blind spot
detection tech that uses the on-board
radar to monitor
each side of the vehicle via interior
mounted screens
the driver can scan the flanks of the
truck better than with the traditional
exterior mounted mirrors
but that doesn't mean it will render
drivers obsolete someone has to be
around to make sure everything's running
smoothly plus the driver can perform
other useful tasks while on the trip
which includes plotting the next trip
checking the conditions of the cargo on
the truck
and bookkeeping the truck essentially
becomes an office space
with video telephone facilities and an
ample amount of space
monotonous long haul trips with tight
schedules can be taxing
but you'll have time to relax enjoy the
view if you're traveling through a quiet
place
and get work done and the view inside
isn't
too bad either typically when you open
up a truck you don't expect much
but the future truck goes above and
beyond
there was no particular need to make it
this luxurious but they did it
the interaction from the second you open
the door is entirely different
design flourishes around the interiors
change conventional semi truck styling
completely
polished wood finishes a large leather
seat and a completely interactive
entertainment system not just for music
but also for browsing social media there
is also storage
above all clad in leather you start the
truck with the start stop button and
drive it onto the highway
once the system takes over the mere push
of a button
glides you smoothly away from the
steering wheel and to the side
to give you ample leg space to stretch
out for more space
there's even a recliner in the back when
the highway pilot is no longer available
the system will prompt you to bring your
seat back and take the wheel the
exterior also has a clean minimal
futuristic look with soft rounded
contours
the led lights in the front turn blue
when the highway pilot mode is on
to warn other drivers and yellow once
the driver is back in control
though the active drive assist feature
in the future truck can steer
break and accelerate on its own the
system doesn't make these calls based on
its own sensors
instead they require a significant
amount of input
by exchanging data with other vehicles
the system is called v-tv
or vehicle-to-vehicle and it uses
satellite navigation to determine its
position
that's why the head of mercedes-benz
trucks stefan buchner
calls the future truck 2025 a fully
connected machine with a hive mentality
this theory of shared intelligence holds
the key to the future
not just for the automotive industry but
also for the industry
as a whole it can digitally link
production processes by exchanging
information between machines
warehouses and other elements involved
in industrial process
chains thereby creating a backbone for
what they call
the fourth industrial revolution aside
from all these features
the future truck also provides certain
opportunities
if you're a truck driver your growth
remains limited
however if the truck is self-driving and
you have time to run logistics
perform bookkeeping and other tasks that
help your company
there is serious potential to move up on
the ladder
because of the different skills you've
gathered being a trucker is a less than
attractive career option right now
and there's a distinct lack of junior
talent but the opportunity to move up
does make it more enticing right now
there's still no word on how much the
truck will cost
semi-autonomous driving technology is
already available on the mercedes
s-class sedans and coupes
but obviously it will have to be
upgraded a lot more to suit the needs of
a truck
even so experts agree that autonomous
vehicles will soon be a reality on the
roads
whether that is in the form of
driverless fleets of taxis
privately owned cars or commercial
vehicles four states in america
nevada florida california and michigan
already permit the use of autonomous
vehicles on public roads
but under certain conditions and the uk
has allowed robotic cars to be used
since 2013 and the future truck is not
riding without competition
tesla the biggest name in electric cars
announced their cyber truck
this all-new electric pickup truck would
take a sledgehammer to a door without so
much as a dent
the base version with a single motor
comes to about forty thousand dollars
and good for a range of 250 miles and a
tow rating of 7
500 pounds a dual motor for 50 000
dollars
can till 10 000 pounds with a range of 3
000 miles
the top of the line version is 70 000
with an impressive
range of 500 miles and a tow rating of
000 pounds they start production on the
vehicle in 2022
so there's a good chance both the
mercedes and the tesla
will hit the market at the same time it
just remains to be seen
who will dominate and there you have it
the mercedes autonomous driving truck
we'll have to wait a while but as we've
seen it's worth the wait
if you enjoyed this video give us a like
and check out our other videos all about
tech over on the simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
in the next video